[Music]
the world is a big place really really
really really really big and we all
experience it differently some people
are obsessed with capturing their
adventure the camera the angles even the
filters wait no not that one
others just want to disconnect they like
solitude huge backpacks and practicing
their bird calls you don't always have
to go far to experience the world you
don't even have to leave your
neighborhood your taste buds are your
travel guide you don't even have to
leave your bedroom to go somewhere new
the only limit is your imagination
also maybe carpal tunnel and everyone's
got that friend that freaks out when
they're cooped up inside they show up to
work on Monday morning with scrapes and
stories they've got a full-blown
adrenalin dependency some people are all
about that itinerary before they visit a
new place they've planned every last
detail but maybe that's not you either
maybe you're a road warrior you've got a
sixth sense for clean gas station
bathrooms or you could be a city scout
there's something really humbling about
all of those big buildings and for some
reason pizza always tastes better when
you're walking I guess we're all seeking
something but when you find yourself out
there something changes and somehow you
just know that no matter what happens
you'll never stop exploring the world
around you
[Music]